so I don't really understand young
people like I know I am one technically
speaking or I'm meant to be at least but
I've always felt like I identify more
with sleepy old men than I do with the
use of today and this is an all young
people be a stereotypical 18 to 25 year
old who goes to lots of parties and has
a lot of fun and says the word Yolo a
lot I find the very confusing however
back in October I found myself doing one
of those things that crazy young people
do and I went on a road trip around
Europe with a bunch of fun-loving
YouTube kids because you know what you
do only live once the whole trip was
organized and paid for by the overly
nice people at Contiki who are a
youth-oriented travel company they plan
out every activity for us even down to
like what food we were eating which as a
self-confessed control freak was pretty
terrifying and one of those things that
continue decided for us was our morning
song which was one song that contiki
played at us every single morning of the
trip when we got on our coach and their
song they picked naturally was we are
young by fun a song rule about being
young and getting drunk and having a
nice time and setting the night on fire
which sounds incredibly dangerous to me
let's just say that it's not a song I
can identify with nor is it a song that
I ever thought I would know all the
lyrics to but I now do the plan was to
visit five different countries in ten
days so we were packing a lion and we
started in Munich Germany around the
time of Oktoberfest which is the world's
largest fair what I found about Germany
is that there is a lot of meats there is
a lot of potatoes and there is a lot of
beer and Oktoberfest specifically is a
temporary Disneyland basically but
specifically for beer and I don't drink
surprisingly so naturally I was a bit
skeptical of the whole thing especially
of the giant beer tents filled to the
brim with drunk people I was surprised
to find though that the rowdiness that I
tend to associate with large amounts of
drinking here in the UK just wasn't
really there everyone was just sort of
nice and jolly our second stuff on the
trip was Austria which became an instant
favorite of mine just because of how
relaxing it was it was beautiful and
quiet and we had this really nice lunch
outside a cabin on a mountainside and we
went on a bike ride in the afternoon and
then we went whitewater rafting which
was
it was very wet and very very cold and
not something that I ever would have
decided to do of my own accord
and was also the most fun that I had on
the entire trip which why I was not
expecting honestly I was just amazed by
how pleased I was that someone else had
forced me to do that because it was just
the best thing country number three was
Italy we stopped off quickly in Verona
which is the setting of Romeo and Juliet
where they have a Juliet's balcony and a
statue of Juliet where the tradition for
some reason is that you go out to her
and you rub her breasts so I did that
obviously and then we went to Venice in
Italy which was a very weird place to
visit because it's a sinking city and
nobody really lives there it's very
eerily quiet but it was also really
weird for me because even though I'd
never been to Venice before I had the
really strange sense of deja vu walking
around the square because some of
Assassin's Creed Brotherhood is set in
Venice the video game and so I walked
around thinking I've climbed to the top
of that Tower and I think I've killed a
man in that Museum my next place was
Paris in France which greatness with a
lovely amount of rain we went up the
Eiffel Tower even though it was too
foggy to really say anything we went to
a cabaret show in the evening and then
we tried some sales because you know
that's just what you do and you're in
Paris and our final stop on the trip was
London England which is here that's
that's where I am right now
we ended our trip in our own dedicated
pod on the London nine and just as a
little raid was coming to an end
everybody around me started singing
[Applause]
and once again I found myself surprised
because I gave him a nice song along
with them and not only that but I
actually enjoyed myself they don't
really know how I feel about it yet to
be honest contiki slogan is no regrets
which has never been a phrase that I've
really liked because to me it only seems
one step away from that kind of Yolo
attitude of let's make the same mistakes
over and over again because we don't
have to think about the consequences of
our actions but I found myself realizing
that no regrets needn't be used as an
excuse to do stupid things it's there as
a motivator to do those things that
you're not sure if you'll enjoy them not
yet because you just haven't tried them
and so although by the end of this trip
I was so exhausted and so happy to be
home I didn't regret going on it in the
slightest there you go there's my cheesy
ending sorry sorry like grew as a person
you've just had the almost imponderable
joy of watching Charlie is so cool like
which makes you like cool